it's really nice to be back because Nia  thanks a chance to thank you all for  last year and also an opportunity for me  to thank the nominees for Best  Supporting Actor this year and for their  marvelous examples of the craft of  acting your skills contribute so much to  our craft because as you know good  acting is never easy so I'm proud to say  your name's Bruce Davison in longtime  companion Andy Garcia in the Godfather  Part 3  Brian Greene and Dances with Wolves  Al Pacino in Dick Tracy  and Joe Pesci in Goodfellas  and the Oscar goes to Joe Pesci in  Goodfellas  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  it's my privilege thank you  [Applause]